une anecdote qui vous a fait sourire
françois truffaut et qui montre bien la
différence entre la télévision et le
cinéma puisque vous considérez que le
cinéma et l'art majeur de la femme
alors votre 21e film sort demain
vivement dimanche point d'exclamation je
crois que vous tenez beaucoup au point
d'exclamation un film en noir et blanc
ce qui dit vous sied un peu ici surtout
quand il est drôle
oui je crois que le noir et blanc nous
permet d'entrer davantage dans
l'histoire parce que c'est un film de
mystère c'est un film nocturne c'est un
film même s'il est traité dans le détail
les situations sont un peu celle des
romans et des films américains
mais le traitement dialoguer le
traitement et humoristique et très
français je crois une histoire et dans
celle d'une secrétaire qui veut sauver
son patron accusé de différents meurtres
voilà c'est ça il l'a fait il a fait
tellement de gaffes qui ne peut plus se
disculper lui-même
donc il a intérêt à se cacher et sa
secrétaire qui avant était son ombre va
faire de lui son nombre et va mener le
plan quête voilà eva voilà avec des gars
fin comme peut faire un amateur ce n'est
pas une enquête menée
professionnellement comme le frêle à la
police évidemment elle tâtonne mais elle
très vaillante plein de bonne volonté et
je crois que là qu'elle réussit alors le
cinéma avez-vous dit dans dans l'un des
entretiens que j'ai lu je croque c'était
dans le matin de paris le cinéma c'est
le contraire d'un journal télévisé
je veux bien vous croire mais en quoi à
dont je parle et là de la forme c'est à
dire dans le journal télévisé
ah oui d'ailleurs cette et curieux parce
qu'aujourd'hui depuis le début de ce
journal nous n'avons eu que des choses
affreuses et qui n'ont pas de
contrepoint et non pas de contrepoint
comique tandis qu évidemment le cinéma
nous donne cette possibilité d'aligner 1
meur demeure cinq meurtres comme dans ce
film là et en même temps que le
traitement soit entièrement le drôle ça
c'est une grande chance évidemment parce
que nous manipulons les choses c'est
tout à fait différent mais là je crois
quand on dit en comparant le cinéma de
fiction est journal télévisé je voulais
dire surtout que dans un film on essaie
d'obtenir une certaine homogénéité de la
forme pour garder l'attention du munci
efforçons aussi rue mais l'actualité
vous êtes l'un des réalisateurs qui
servez le mieux les femmes si je vous
dis et en l'occurrence dans ce film
fanny ardant vous considérez que le
cinéma c'est avant tout l'art de la
femme de l'actrice et bien c'est surtout
que je fais des films qui ne sont pas
tellement inscrits socialement sont des
films ceux où les sentiments compte
beaucoup les rapports affectifs comme
beaucoup quelquefois des films sur les
enfants les parents les hommes et les
femmes
et à ce moment là je crois que
évidemment en écrivant l'histoire même
sens que je le veuille le rôle de la
femme devient plus décisif que plus
important mais enfin compte tenu de sa
je fais en sorte que les rôles d'hommes
soit correctement écrit agréable à jouer
pour les acteurs mais enfin c'est le
point commun à le vivement dimanche
appartient à fanny ardant comme le
dernier métro était conduit par
catherine deneuve je pense que c'est
l'histoire qui demande ça chaque fois
fanny ardant qui en l'occurrence est
accompagné si j'ose dire de jean louis
trintignant
voilà son patron qui donc a mené pendant
un certain temps à rester dans l'ombre
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas pendant une
partie du film on est elle pense qu'il
est innocent mais peut-être qu'elle se
trompe
eh bien merci françois truffaut vivement
dimanche plutôt vivement demain mercredi
là